but i actually wanted to to really make
this this point clear there is no one
way to do science dave like you asked me
in the beginning about science there is
no science says or follow this there's
not even science like science uh is
essentially basically a you know a
shortcut a hack for us unraveling
fundamental truths that never is perfect
is guaranteed to be imperfect
sheldon glashow the nucleator
shelley or sheldon glashow so he's the
namesake inspiration for the big bang uh
theories uh sheldon young sheldon
sheldon um he's a throwback to he's an
older guy and and he
really you know made his way doing
something quite unique my wife told me
last night she was reading it and yeah i
wrote another book before this i'm not
convinced she read that book dave don't
tell her i said so although she's a big
fan of yours so she she'll be
disappointed to know if you read that
first book and not this anyway so she
was reading less she's like this is so
appropriate because what he discovered
like um the discovery that electricity
and magnetism and technical physics
terms are basically two different
aspects of one underlying physical law
and that's called electromagnetism so
that you can turn a small current can
move a motor and spin a motor you can
also spin that motor and generate a
current that's in fact how current and
electrical power generation works
so he discovered the analog of that
unification in what's called the nuclear
force it's not super important to get
into but it really delineated how these
things that we perceive very different a
magnet that you put in your refrigerator
and uh you know a 9-volt battery they
seem very different but they are
different manifestations of the same
underlying coin he did so with his
colleagues stephen weinberg and abdul
salam in the 60s and 70s they discovered
a similar feature of uh the nuclear
force and my wife was reading and she
said
this is so interesting because what one
person perceives as a manifestation say
pure electricity another will perceive
as magnetism or as one person sees as
electricity we'll see as a nuclear force
that's so interesting because could you
imagine dave as you do often and you
talk about in your book
can you argue the other person's side
can you do that because otherwise as you
said i might like debate is kind of
pointless like oh joe biden did a great
you know debating with trump i'm gonna
vote for him now as a die hard no that
never happened but if you can say i see
your perspective right and literally it
is just as kosher just as good as
another person's perspective well then
why not use that as a metaphor for how
we could be maybe a little less
polarized so i like that she got i
wasn't intending to say that um but but
it did come out and uh from her
interpretation of reading this chapter
about how things that appear so
different dave are really the same
manifestation of of of the underlying
same phenomenon we actually could use a
little bit more of that in politics i'm
sure i could use a little bit more of it
personally as well uh then there's an
interstitial should we go into the
interstitial why'd you throw an
interstitial into the book
what's going on here
i got paid by the word
it's a short book you know and it's it's
not there's no physics equations there's
no homework uh you know although you you
know you being a master of quantum
electrodynamics would have done quite
well if there were exactly i had uh
custom illustrations and i should say i
have a podcast where i give away all
these interviews you don't have to buy
the hope you will i hope you'll get the
audio or the the printed book but um but
i actually wanted to to really make this
this point clear there is no one way to
do science dave like you asked me in the
beginning about science there is no
science says or follow this there's not
even science like science uh is
essentially
basically a you know a shortcut a hack
for us unraveling fundamental truths
that never is perfect is guaranteed to
be imperfect and so some of us gives
great comfort because you can never get
the right answer in other words newton
was darn smart and he is responsible for
the laws that take elon musk's spacex to
the to the stars and took the apollo
astronauts to the surface of the moon um
but if you want to go and understand the
properties of a black hole his work will
not do and you need einstein well guess
what
einstein's not the right answer either
we're gonna find some subsequent
improvement to it maybe quantum gravity
which we'll you know we'll get it we
have a ten part learning company series
you and i on that so we can refer people
to that lecture series but that's not
quite
that's and guess what that won't be the
final answer either so i want to show
that there's different approaches to
arriving at truth you can manifest them
i was talking to uh tom bilya who lives
in l.a is a famous podcaster great guy i
had him on the show i was actually at
his laboratory and he told me his way
that he works through you know when he
was at quest nutrition and he was
developing these really tasty but
nutritious bars protein bars whatever
and the scientific method that he was
using
and how he also applies it to venture
capital or to now he's into nfts and
bitcoin and stuff like that but it's a
it's a process of thinking guaranteed to
be imperfect but better than all the
rest so i want to outline how you can do
it my avatar is a is a car salesman in
tulsa oklahoma
it's not a scientist it's not written
for science science majors and that you
can apply methodological thinking
testing hypotheses listening to your
critics
achieving consensus and realizing in
surreptitiously perhaps that when you
hear things like 99 percent of
scientists agree you should be very
concerned
you should be very we hear an awful lot
about that these days uh on many fronts
actually not just covid climate change
all sorts of things uh carl wyman the
teacher's teacher
yeah so for a long time i had been kind
of an acolyte of malcolm gladwell uh who
you know popularized he didn't invent
this this uh this this concept but the
so-called 10 000 hour rule so i did a
little math you've been doing podcasting
uh the reuben report you've been on you
know 2000's early 2000's you've had way
more than 10 000 hours but the study
that gladwell and uh and anders erickson
popularized was that basically the best
pilots have ten thousand hours of flight
experience bill gates had like ten
thousand hours of computer programming
by the time microsoft steve jobs had ten
thousand yeah so he done it's basically
it's not a scientific analysis it's
really correlative um and i wanted to
know well we as professors we
never really get taught how to teach
it's very rare you may be interested in
teaching in pedagogy but we have so many
other obligations in addition to
teaching research funding uh bureaucracy
you know and and getting through you
know all the different hoops of working
not just at a state university any
university um and then teaching is on
there and it's a big priority it's the
reason we get into it but oftentimes
we're
distracted by other quotidian demands
and in this case i wanted to kind of
demystify how should we be teaching
because i don't know if you know it but
the way that we teach with like some
dude scraping a piece of rock on another
piece of rock that is almost exactly a
thousand-year-old model it's not been
disrupted since the year 1080 in bologna
italy when the first modern university
incarnation came along where you'd have
some guy you know and but the only thing
that's better now is that back then dave
the students could go on strike and the
professors would not get paid so thank
god we have tenure i mean that you know
that's barbaric that is a barbaric
practice but other than that what has
changed so i got into all sorts of
things could we have an artificial
intelligent professor could we alleviate
some of the the burden but also free up
the the minds and the time of the
student to do it and he likened our
current practice of teaching to the
medical practices of the 18 and 17th
century with leeches and bloodletting he
said we're at a primitive state and we
need to go beyond that he has some
models to do it i don't think any of
them are foolproof but the key takeaway
i took dave is that
to be a good teacher you have to be a
student of teaching
and i pointed out in the book that the
word scientist in the russian language
means someone who was taught to me that
conveys an obligation you both have to
be a good student but you have to be a
good teacher to pay it forward to the
next generation and so i think he
exemplifies that to me and really made
me want to double down and be a better
teacher
by studying teaching and that's not
something i really have that much time
to do but i find a little bit of effort
goes a long way with it and i hope in
anybody's field the way to learn
something to be a better salesman to be
a better podcaster i think i asked you
when you came out i was like how do you
know dave when you're giving a good
interview when you're doing a good job
as an intern like there's no like you
don't have a grader anymore but you must
study it and you must listen to it and
even if that means studying with people
that maybe you don't agree with all the
time um you can learn a lot and that's
part of the humble uh you know nature
that i think it takes to be a good
student and ergo a good teacher if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell